er ist der elfte präsident der
bundesrepublik deutschland joachim gauck
wie kaum ein anderer zuvor steht gauck
ein für freiheit und verantwortung für
demokratie solidarität und zivilcourage
joachim gauck weiß wovon er spricht als
evangelischer pastor in der ddr machte
er aus seiner starts kritischen haltung
keinen hehl und war mitinitiator des
widerstandes gegen die diktatur
nach der wende war er zehn jahre lang
bundesbeauftragter für die
stasi-unterlagen seit 2012 schließlich
amtete er als bundespräsident
übermorgen kommt joachim gauck zu einem
offiziellen besuch in die schweiz nur
die trecker hat sich mit ihm schon vorab
getroffen und über die schweiz und
europa den mauerfall und die beiden
weltkriege unterhalten das gespräch fand
in berlin statt dem amtssitz des
bundespräsidenten im schloss bellevue
herr bundespräsident in kürze brechen
sie auf seinem offiziellen schweiz
besucht was für eine beziehung haben sie
zur schweiz was verbindet sie mit
unserem land ich habe eine sehr gute
beziehung zu ihrem land und eigentlich
müsste ich jetzt sagen es ist eine
doppelte eine die früh entstanden ist
als ich in der ddr lebte also im
kommunistischen machtbereich und als
junge alles gelesen habe was mit
freiheit zusammenhängt und so liest dann
der zwölfjährige schüler wilhelm tell
und findet das wunderbar dass es helden
gibt die sich gegen diktatoren auflehnen
mein vater ist in der zeit gerade in
sibirien was ich nicht weiß ich weiß nur
er ist abgeholt und ich lebe in einem
regime das sich fortschrittlich nennt
aber eine diktatur ist
und dann liest man von solchen
wunderbaren figuren und sarkasmus ja ein
großartiges land sein schnitt das ist
also ein sehnsuchts bild und jetzt habe
ich
eine auf erfahrung und freundschaft
gestützte gute beziehung freundschaft
weil ich mit menschen die dort leben
freundschaftlich verbunden sind und
erfahrung ist das gefühl wenn ich in die
schweiz komme ich komme in ein
kerneuropa und zwar deshalb weil in die
schweiz viel früher als andere
ein zusammenleben der unterschiedlichen
der unterschiedlichen sprachen der
unterschiedlichen religionen der
unterschiedlichen traditionen
zusammengefügt hat sie hat dieses
zusammenleben gestaltet vielleicht als
friedliche koexistenz vielleicht auch
dann als freundschaft vielleicht bei
manchen nur aus pragmatismus aber die
ganze zeit sind die verschiedenen
zusammen geblieben wie ein kleines
europa wie eine idee von einem europa
der verschiedenen die sich verbünden in
eine konföderation ihr ein schönes bild
wie würden sie denn das verhältnis
unserer beider länder heute bezeichnen
oder beschreiben
ich glaube dass die ich will nicht sagen
alle so was gibt es nicht aber dass die
ganz überwiegende zahl der deutschen
eine große hochachtung hat vor der
schweiz auch respekt auch dankbarkeit
dass hier eine demokratie existiert die
niemals zu einer diktatur geworden ist
die friedliebend ist die auch allerhand
für den zusammenhalt der
unterschiedlichen menschen in europa
getan hat und vielleicht auch die
neutralität die viele beeindruckt aber
ich denke dass ein sehr sehr positives
bild das wir haben von der schweiz
ich weiß nicht wie die schweizer auf
deutschland schauen vielleicht das ist
traditionell anders als gerade aktuell
da würde ich jetzt nicht so gern
stellung nehmen wenn man sich jetzt
konkret der größere politische projekte
anstatt wie zum beispiel steuerabkommen
oder fluglärm staatsvertrag
da kommt man ja nicht vom fleck also ist
man sich menschlich nah aber politisch
standort fern
na ja also es ist schon wichtig dass
eine historisch gefestigte nation wie
die schweiz das ist mit ihrer nicht so
enormen größe sich über gegenüber einem
sehr großen nachbarn der auch in der
geschichte oftmals ein gefährlicher
nachbar war nur ein selbstbewusstes wir
sind die schweiz bewahrt hat und was die
deutschen betrifft so sind sie ja nach
der phase des historischen übermut wenn
ich gerade mit einem sehr großen mit
einer sehr großen ich stärke gesegnet
sie trumpfen also nicht auf also es ist
eher eine ausnahme vielleicht gibt es
das mal im fußball oder es gibt es in
der in der ökonomie dass wir uns
ziemlich großartig vorkommen aber ich
glaube nicht dass es eine neigung gibt
die anderen nun irgendwie nominieren zu
wollen oder sind ins unrecht setzen zu
wollen
ich verstehe es auch nicht so recht
warum es manchmal knirscht
also wenn wir nicht auch ganz aktuelle
dinge kommen dann fehlt mir irgendein
zitat ein
das so klingt als wären die deutschen
darauf versessen gegenüber den
schweizern herauszukehren wie groß sie
sind aber das ist
nicht so dass das die deutsche
mentalität durchziehen würde nun hat ja
die schweiz am 19 februar für
schlagzeilen gesorgt mit der annahme der
initiative gegen masseneinwanderung wir
haben sie persönlich reagiert auf dieses
abstimmungsergebnis persönlich war ich
traurig meine freunde die ich habe in
der schweiz die gehört nicht zu den
befürwortern und man lässt sich ja
leicht von den menschen die einem ans
herz gewachsen sind dann auch in seiner
eigenen meinung beeinflussen aber
natürlich als politisch einigermaßen
sache europäer hat es mir auch nicht
gefallen und da bin ich doch recht
skeptisch weil ich so eine mischung aus
aha eine selbstbewusste bevölkerung
aha die sind auch selbstbewusst wenn
alle autoritäten politik kultur ökonomie
kirchen wenn alle eine andere meinung
haben dann sagen sie acht das wollen wir
noch mal sehen und stimmen dann in der
weise ab wie sie es getan haben ja
vielleicht zeigt uns dieses diese
abstimmung und das ergebnis der
abstimmung auch dass ein reizvolles
politik modell wie das der direkten
demokratie auch irgendwie immer ein aber
hat ja es ist dann nicht so dass das
ergebnis zustande kommt dass sich die
besonders einsichtigen endung gewünscht
hätten
ich bin traurig gewesen war ich in
anfangs in unserem gespräch signalisiert
habe wie mein bild von der schweiz ist
es für mich ein kleines und frühes
europa eine vereinigung der
verschiedenen und ich wünschte mir so
sehr an der schweiz gebe es eine
stimmung in europa dabei zu sein in der
gemeinschaft dabei zu sein ich sehe die
im moment natürlich nicht aber ich
wünsche es mir und ich glaube es gibt
viele europäer die sich das wünschen von
der demokratischen reife der schweizer
zu profitieren auch von der fähigkeit
kompromisse zu gestalten oder aber
können sie gewisse ängste von
schweizerinnen
verstehen die jetzt im zusammenhang mit
einwandert ja das kann ich verstehen
weil ich das in deutschland ja in
verschiedenen wellen in den
zurückliegenden jahren auch gesehen habe
so merkwürdig dass manchmal ängste
besonders dort besonders heftig sind wo
es wenig ausländer gibt also dafür war
nach dem zusammenwachsen deutschlands
nach der einheit ganz typisch dass in
großen bereichen ostdeutschlands wo kaum
ausländer und zuwanderer migranten
lebten dass da diese anti stimmung
besonders großer das heißt wir müssen
uns eigentlich klar machen fremdheit und
der andere der erzeugt manchmal neugier
aber manchmal auch angst der ist ja
anders
und dieses anderssein wird nicht immer
gleich als eine einladung kommen näher
und lernen mich kennen verstanden
sondern bedroht mich das und ich hatte
ein bisschen verwundert dass die schweiz
mit ihrem wirklich gewachsenen bürger
bewusst sein dass in dort auch diese
abgrenzung tendenzen
[Musik]
doch immerhin so groß war dass eine
gewisse mehrheit dann dieses ergebnis
erbracht hat ich will jetzt nicht wirken
müssen wie einer der eine
meinungsäußerung der bevölkerung
zensiert ich habe ganz bewusst gesagt
ich als person war traurig und ich als
europäer hätte mir und das will ich
schon frei heraus sagen ich hätte mir
ein anderes ergebnis gewünscht und ich
bin auch ein bisschen besorgt denn jetzt
kommen komplizierte verhandlungen auf
die schweiz und die europäer zu wenn man
ein element ablehnt dieses element der
freizügigkeit dann sind andere elemente
da die dann auch nicht mehr gelten so
sind jedenfalls die verträge ja das ist
das ist schwierig es gab natürlich auch
stimmen nach der abstimmung die sagten
also been in deutschland diese
möglichkeit bestünde über sowas
abzustimmen dann wäre das genau so
rausgekommen glauben sie dass ich möchte
das nicht glauben aber und ich bin auch
nicht sicher will es kommt auch zum teil
darauf an wie die kampagne läuft und wie
die stimmung gerade ist ob es so ein
hoch gibt von ängstlichkeit und
abgrenzung sbe dürfen ist oder ob es
eine sicherheit wir haben doch bisher
unsere krisen ganz gut gemeistert oder
wir brauchen doch zuwanderung ob mich
dann doch eine mehrheit gewesen wäre die
gesagt hat nein das wollen wir nicht wir
sind moderner europäer wir haben in
langen jahren über freizügigkeit geredet
wir haben das für und wider erwogen wir
sind mehr dafür aber in jeder
europäischen bevölkerung gibt es eine
kleinere oder größere gruppe die den die
diese freizügigkeit oder die tatsache
dass wir nie mehr so eine homogene
bevölkerung gesagt werden
die daraus mehr ängste als hoffnung
ableitet und wir können in jedem land
europa sehen was wirkt dann befördert
was befördert die ängste und die
abgrenzung tendenz und was wird
eigentlich helfen um diese zuwanderung
der
derer die die noch fremd sind zu
akzeptieren zu verstehen oder sich gar
darüber zu freuen wenn es so wird das in
bestimmten quartieren also diejenigen
die die landessprache sprechen das
gefühl haben wir sind umgeben von
menschen die das nicht mehr sprechen
oder in einer schulklasse dass die
deutsch sprechen oder die die
heimatsprache sprechenden in eine große
minderheit geraten dann kommen diese
abwehrreflexe neuer in der schule kann
man schon dafür sorgen dass man solche
klassen nicht entstehen lässt sondern
dass man eine vernünftige durchmischung
dann hinkriegt in den schulklassen und
wir haben hier in deutschland in der
letzten zeit einige male über
zuwanderung aus bulgarien und rumänien
speziell der roma bevölkerung diskutiert
und wir sehen einen unterschiedlichen
großstädten unterschiedliche strategien
die unterzubringen wo es dann zu einer
art massen zusammen leben kommt einer
bestimmten ethnie da ist es schwieriger
wenn man die verteilen kann in
unterschiedlichen stadtquartiere und
dafür gibt es in deutschland auch ein
beispiel
dann kommt es nicht zu dieser zuspitzung
und dann ist auch die neigung der
zugewanderten sich stärker an der umwelt
zu orientieren größer als wenn es dieses
unmittelbare enger aufeinander sitzen
gibt wo dann die ordnungsliebe oder die
sitten und gebräuche die ordnungsämter
und die öffentlichkeit gerne haben
möchte die mannschaft nicht durchgesetzt
würden also man kann da schon eingreifen
jetzt beim thema an dieser abstimmung
sind sie froh dass in deutschland keine
direkte demokratie sondern eine
repräsentative gerade wenn wir dann
solche abstimmung wie die
masseneinwanderung denken
naja ich habe mir meine meinung schon
vorher gebildet vor diesem referendum
also ich bin als ich als gestalter in
die politik eingestiegen bin ich sagte
schon dass ich aus dem osten
deutschlands komme also ich war früher
nicht teil des politikbetriebes sondern
ein evangelischer pfarrer
aber ich war dann 89 teil der
demokratiebewegung und von daher musste
ich mir genau überlegen welche republik
welche demokratie wollen wird und in
dieser aufbruch phase war die direkte
demokratie gerade bei den bürgerbewegten
ein gros eine große hoffnung wir haben
also in sehr vielen papieren und
veranstaltungen dafür geworben dass wir
mehr direkte demokratie haben ich finde
auch die beschäftigung damit auch die
implementierung deshalb gut weil es mehr
menschen beteiligt an der gestaltung der
demokratie nur ich bin je länger ich
hier in der repräsentativen demokratie
dann gelebt habe zum teil auch politik
gemacht da wir der ansicht dass sich
dieses modell der repräsentativen
demokratie bewährt hat ist es
insbesondere für so ein großes land wie
deutschland das modell dass uns die
ökonomischen und politischen auch
kulturellen erfolge gebracht hatte wir
haben keinen grund es abzuschaffen und
müssen nur fragen wir möchten mehr leute
beteiligen wo sind die ebenen in der
kommune in den bundes in den ländern des
bundes wo die menschen mehr mitbestimmen
können ohne dass sie nun immer in der
gefahr sind hoch komplexe themen
das muss ja nicht immer ein eu thema
sein oder ausländer das kann manchmal
die gestaltung der gesundheitsfürsorge
sein wie wie soll die krankenkassen
ausgestattet werden oder wie soll das
steuersystem sein also hochkomplexe
fragen in ein schema zu pressen wo man
ja oder nein entscheidungen fällen muss
das ist schon für für eine so
ausdifferenzierte gesellschaft wäre das
ein riesenprogramm nein ich möchte dass
wir dieses system der repräsentativen
demokratie beibehalten und uns erinnern
an die guten zeiten und guten ergebnisse
die wir damit geschaffen haben und haben
sie ihren bürgerinnen und bürgern nicht
ein bisschen wenig zu würde ich nicht
sagen
sondern es ist so ich habe ja von
erfahrungen gesprochen nicht von
misstrauen misstrauen waren damals als
wir nach dem krieg als die deutschen im
westen das grundgesetz geschrieben haben
da war man die väter und mütter der
verfassung waren noch voller sorge dass
das volk eben sich ein diktator wieder
wählen konnte und hatte die
verführbarkeit auch großer
bevölkerungsgruppen in der nazi zeit
noch in unmittelbarer erinnerung und
wissen sie die deutschen die nach dem
krieg lebten das waren auch nicht die
aufgeklärten deutschen und die
demokratie freunde die wir heute haben
in deutschland als ganz ganz große
mehrheit sondern es waren menschen die
unsicher waren und deshalb kam so ein
frühes naja misstrauen würde ich sagen
aber ein begründetes misstrauen der
verantwortlichen in der politik da gibt
es keinen grund mehr das ist so aber es
ist effektive was wir haben und es ist
so dass große grundsatzentscheidung etwa
der politischen richtungen denken wir
mal an den großen plan europa zu
vereinigen
dass wir da mitunter eine
gruppe aus der bevölkerung beauftragte
sie sind ja aus der bevölkerung heraus
gewählt
spezialisten für politik die zeit
energie fach expertise einbeziehen in
lange überlegungen wie soll die zukunft
europa gestellt europas gestellt werden
die das dann abstimmen lassen im
parlament so dass man nicht sagen kann
das ist undemokratisch nur das ist auf
dem wege einer repräsentativen
demokratie demokratisch und das sind die
guten erfahrungen die für mich
ausschlaggebend sind und bundeslandebene
oder auf der kommunalen ebene würden sie
sagen auf der das hat sich gezeigt also
wenn wir zum beispiel die nachbarn ihre
nachbarn die bayern anschauen die haben
in ihrer verfassung umfangreiche
mitwirkungsmöglichkeiten der bevölkerung
oder die bayerische bevölkerung hat sich
auch an allerlei mitwirkung außerhalb
von wahlen für die repräsentativen
versammlung oder fürs parlament gewählt
das ist dass es auch schön zu sehen und
manchmal geht es dann auch gegen die
politik das muss man wirklich sagen aber
bei diesem großen nationalen anliegen
bleibe ich mal bei dieser auffassung
dass sich unser system bewertet
aber grundsätzlich appellieren sie ja
immer wieder auch und den mündigen
bürgern der aktiven bürger der sich eben
wirklich beteiligt und engagiert
politisch und von daher sind
wahrscheinlich jetzt ist
bürgerbeteiligung ja das demokratischen
elemente
das passt zu meinem bild von von einer
bürgergesellschaft und deshalb ist
dieses grundsätzliche misstrauen auch
nicht mein ding
sondern ich beziehe mich hier
ausdrücklich auf die positiven erfahrung
in der geschichte der der letzten 60
jahre
besonders im freien teil deutschlands
und der osten hat das so übernommen und
würde jetzt auch mehrheitlich wenn wir
den der bevölkerung die frage stellen
wollen wollte in dem schweizer system
oder wollt ihr bei uns im system bleiben
glaube ich nicht dass es eine mehrheit
gegen die repräsentative demokratie
geben würden
jetzt noch mal ganz kurz zurück zu zur
massen einwanderungs initiative da gab
es ja von verschiedenen ländern von
europäischen ländern auch zustimmung aus
frankreich zb belgien aus holland sie
als überzeugter europäer muss das
beunruhigend es mich ja und ich will
auch gerne sagen dass mich das mich
beunruhigt hat dass wir im zuge einer
immer weiter auf eine union zu gehen
politik bewegung plötzlich in alten
demokratie in nicht nur in frankreich
wie sie eben sind bei ihnen auch in den
niederlanden oder in dänemark
das sind ja gesellschaften die wir
deutsche besonders nach dem krieg sehr
stark bewundert haben auch ihre weil sie
eben nicht abgegolten sind die
diktatoren und nun sehen wir dass sich
sogar in skandinavien was wir deutsche
auch immer sehr bewundern wegen ihrer
demokratischen traditionen die sie
geschaffen haben und wegen der
friedfertigen politik dass ich überall
in unseren nachbarländern
solche starken zum teil national
populistisch konnotierten strömungen und
bewegungen herausgebildet haben
und einige haben dann in deutschland
damit gerechnet das werden wir auch sehr
bald
denken sie mal auch an österreich die
entwicklung dort bricht das sind leute
die uns auch zum teil sehr ähnlich sind
jetzt hat sich aber in deutschland
glaube ich doch gezeigt dass die
intensive beschäftigung mit den fehlern
der nation auch mit der schuld der
nation dass der intensive schuld des
chors in der erwachsenen bundesrepublik
eine gewisse vorsicht einmal davor
überhaupt die nationale karte zu spielen
und erst recht aber von nationalismus
entstanden ist so dass alle strömungen
die auf ein starkes nationalgefühl
setzen das ist überbordend ist das die
bisher nicht erfolgreich
in deutschland es gab immer mal
kurzzeitig rechtsextreme parteien die
hier oder da erfolgreich waren die sind
nie ins in den deutschen bundestag
eingedrungen und das hat sich auch immer
wieder schnell gegeben als nun diese
größeren volksbewegung waren die waren
ja nicht sagen wir immer nationalistisch
oder gar rechtsextreme aber sie haben
doch eine andere karte ausgespielt eine
andere trumpfkarte
und das war die eigene nation und ich
kann das am besten verstehen wenn ich
nicht im raster eines
politikwissenschaftlers oder historikers
argumentiere sondern wenn ich mir
vorstelle welche zumutungen die moderne
für den einzelnen das individuum
bereithält muss er begreifen ich werde
nicht fortwährend durchs leben geführt
durch eine autorität wie es früher
einmal war durch einen weisen fürsten
oder ein könig oder einen der alles weiß
ich als bürger bin unabhängig und frei
mein leben zu gestalten
das ist eine chance aber es macht mir
immer ein wenig angst und das nächste
und jetzt haben wir uns an unseren
nationen gewöhnt die deutschen und die
italiener spät
sie brauchten lange um eine nationale
identität zu entwickeln vorher waren sie
bayern hessen thüringen sachsen und so
weiter und jetzt sollten sie deutschen
sein
1871 kommt es zu dieser reichsgründung
ähnlich in italien und jetzt haben wir
das noch mehr oder weniger die deutschen
schlecht diese nationale karte gespielt
weil sie übrigens geführt hat aber bei
anderen ist das nie so schuld beladen
und der weg in ein vereinigtes europa
der uns als ein wunderbares hoffnungs
und friedens modell erschienen ist hängt
auch mit der mit dem abschied von
überschaubaren räumen und einer
eingeübten identität zusammen
ich bin dann eben nicht mehr nur däne
oder niederländer oder deutsche sondern
auch europäer und ich gebe dafür auch
kompetenzen ab an ein europa ja wo ist
es wie sprechen die dort
und so ist im grunde diese furcht die
wir haben wenn wir neue räume betreten
oder wenn uns etwas fremdes begegnet das
äußert sich nicht nur individuell
sondern auch in der in dem kollektiven
ich einer bevölkerung
und dann gibt es diese abgrenzung stents
und dann kommt es sehr stark darauf an
dass dort in den politischen mit
unterschiedlichen politischen milieus
personen sind die mit ihrer eigenen
glaubwürdigkeit und mit der
glaubwürdigkeit eines friedens und
erfolgs programms werben für dieses
gefühl wir verlieren uns nicht wenn wir
uns in einer erweiterten konföderation
zusammenfügen wie eng nun auch immer
aber es ist töricht anzunehmen dass jede
erweiterung des raumes in dem
gemeinschaften leben dass die nur mit
freude und begeisterung begleitet wird
sondern auch immer mit der sorge da wird
es den gut gehen und muss ich nicht mehr
abgeben als ich bekomme insofern ist das
was wir erleben dieses hin und her bei
einem bei der schaffung eines
vereinigten europas eigentlich etwas was
wir aus der entwicklung von
nationalstaaten die sich aus
verschiedenen ländern fürstentümer
zusammengesetzt haben was wir kennen
müssten nur das ist zu lange weg und wir
denken jetzt uns widerfährt etwas ganz
besonderes und etwas bedrohliches und
manche menschen haben die neigung sich
eher zu fürchten als sich zu freuen und
genau das findet dann auch einen
politischen ausdruck
die frage ist ja auch ob das projekt die
idee europa auch das friedensprojekt und
sich dass der jungen generation noch
vermitteln lässt also jener generation
die in europa nur im frieden kennt ihr
ja an kriegen auf dem hörensagen kennt
ich hatte noch vor einem halben jahr
gesagt ja das ist richtig wir brauchen
eine andere erzählung als die tiefe
meine generation so wichtig war diese
länder die sich hier verbünden werden
nie wieder feinde oder gar erzfeinde
sein sie werden nie wieder krieg
miteinander führen und
für die älteren ist das so großartig und
überwältigend dass sie von dieser idee
wirklich erfüllt waren
und sie haben völlig recht meine kinder
und meine enkel erst recht dieser spruch
selbstverständlich was willst du
eigentlich alter mann ja und ja erzähl
mal vom krieg so ungefähr aber das doch
nicht unsere wirklichkeit
jetzt aber wo wir zwei mal erlebt haben
in einer kurzen zeit dass wir noch nicht
im reich des friedens angekommen sind
und dass sich länder am rande europas
plötzlich wieder bedroht fühlen wie die
ukraine vom großmacht streben des
russischen nachbarn oder wie die ex
sowjetrepubliken estland lettland
litauen und der nachbar polen wie die
mit einer irgendwie erfahrungs
gesättigten angst richtung osten schaut
da merkt man plötzlich dass die garantie
des friedens und eine ordnung des
friedens etwas ist was für uns wichtig
bleibt und ich erinnere auch an das was
auf dem balkan passiert ist ein großer
teil europas war schon so befriedet wie
ich es eben dargestellt haben krieg ist
überhaupt nicht mehr möglich ist auch
institution institutionell nicht mehr
möglich ist war
europa ist ja im grunde ein
institutionalisierter lernprozess
europäischer völker und während das
schon wirklichkeit ist ist in einem
anderen teil europas auf dem balkan noch
die wirklichkeit von vor 100 jahren
blutige hochaktuelle und friedliche
kriegerische wirklichkeit mit folter
mord vergewaltigung ja sogar tendenzen
zum völkermord
dies hat sich doch wieder neu für mich
ein geprägt so dass ich denke dass nicht
nur meine generation sondern auch die
ihrige den jungen leuten in der schule
sein muss wisst ihr das friedensprojekt
ist noch jung und es ist immer noch
gefährdet
aber natürlich müssen wir mehr erzielen
wir müssen ihnen erzählen ihre eigene
erfahrung sprechen müssen sie manchmal
muss man selbstverständlichkeiten
das ist wie in einer partnerschaft wenn
du nie mehr sagst ich liebe dich dann
ist die selbstverständlichkeit einer
partnerschaftlichen liebe irgendwann
auch ein bisschen bedroht man muss
sprechen können was existiert und darum
müssen wir mit denen die dieses europa
erleben darüber sprechen es benennen was
uns verbindet dass wir jederzeit
woanders hin kommen wenn die lebenswelt
gehen können wenn die lebensverhältnisse
in meinem heimatort prekär sind dass sie
uns ausbildungsstätten suchen können
dass wir keinen pass mehr brauchen dass
wir mit unserem personalausweis grenzen
überwinden können und dass wir
aufeinander achten
in diesem vereinigten europa ob wir von
den werten auf die wir geschworen haben
die menschen richtig die bürgerrechte
die herrschaft des rechtes ob einer aus
unserer mitte weg geht davon aus welchen
gründen auch immer sie haben erlebt als
in ungarn sich die künstler oder
journalisten sorgen gemacht haben um
ihre eigene freiheit wie intensiv das
gespräch der europäer dann war mit einem
solchen land das hat die regierung hat
gesagt wie ihr es ist doch alles völlig
okay aber schon der anschein dass das
hier eine einschränkung von gewachsenen
rechten und berechtigungen existieren
würde hat dafür gesorgt dass die
europäer sich verantwortlich fühlen und
das müssen wir mit unseren jungen leuten
besprechen dass wir nicht nur einen raum
des friedens haben sie auch einen raum
der rechtssicherheit und sie spüren was
das bedeuten kann wenn sie in
schwellenländer gehen wenn sie gar auf
ihren reisen durch die welt in
diktaturen oder autoritären im autoritär
regierten ländern leben sie spüren wie
großartig das ist wenn man sich auf eine
behörde eine institution verlassen kann
ja all das ist auch eben europa es sich
vielleicht die frage wie sehr europa
noch vision hat für junge europäerinnen
und europäer zum beispiel die keine
arbeit haben die
im moment jedenfalls wenig perspektive
haben da stellt sich ja manchmal so da
als wären bestimmte teile europas schuld
an dem was in anderen teilen passiert
und da gibt es so eine ungesunde nord
süd debatte manchmal dass die deutschen
und ihre nördlichen und östlichen
nachbarn auf der einen seite stehen und
spanien italien griechenland auf der
anderen seite wenn wir genau hinschauen
dann sehen wir relativ früh auch schon
vor der finanzkrise strukturelle
probleme in diesen krisen ländern im
süden und ich stelle mir manchmal vor
die europäer insgesamt hätten sich nicht
bewegt um eingriff szenarien zu schaffen
deutschland hätte nur gesagt spart
solidität und hätte nicht sich
bereitgefunden die mechanismen wsm und
fiskal vertrag und so weiter doch
mitzutragen
wie es dann dort aussehen würde das
heißt wir müssen den jungen jungen
menschen in spanien oder in italien und
griechenland sagen dass wir uns um ihre
zukunft gedanken machen wir müssen
miteinander darum ringen nicht nur ad
hoc programme aufzulegen die sie aus
aktuelle not heraus wird sondern
ausbildungssysteme zu schaffen wie wir
sie in der schweiz in österreich und in
deutschland und in vielen anderen
ländern kennen wo man sich früh um die
karriere der jungen leute sorgen macht
und ihnen eine aus ein ausbildungsmodell
anbietet was es zum teil in diesen
ländern noch nicht gibt das sind sehr
konkrete zum teil auch ein wenig teure
projekte und wir werden sie angehen
müssen und stecke also das sind
das sind konflikte und probleme die
gestaltbar sind und ich habe so ein
wenig angst davor dass eine
so eine depressive phase über uns kommt
mein gott wie groß sind die probleme und
dann praktisch die rückfahrkarte gelöst
wird in eine nationalstaatliche
isolation und das dafür habe ich kein
schönes bild
es ist hat die schweiz nicht mitglied
der eu ich weiß sie bedauern das was
würden sie sagen welche rolle kann die
schweiz trotzdem einnehmen in der eben
auch als nichtmitglied was ich mir
wünsche ist dass das wohl gleich
eingangs sprach diese ja eigentlich
jahrhundertelange erfahrung der menschen
die in der konfiguration zusammenleben
das dass die uns erzählen wie langsam
aber doch intensiv die staatlichkeit der
verschiedenen wachsen kann also dass das
die französisch sprachigen und die
schweizerdeutsch sprechen wird dass die
italienisch sprachigen und dass alle
diese die ladinische konnte das all das
zusammen gefunden ist und das auch in
einem recht komplizierten
gestaltungsprozess mit der direkten
demokratie immer fahrt das ja zur
demokratie und zum beieinander bleiben
gewirkt hat das ist gemeine eine
europäische kostbarkeit und die
schweizer und so viele intellektuelle so
viele schweizer bürger haben versucht
aus diesem wissen heraus
demokratie funktioniert auch mit den
sehr unterschiedlichen mit den
hochgestellten und den ärmeren mit den
so oder so sozialisiert und mit den so
oder so glauben das sind ist eine
gewachsene selbstverständlichkeit das
ist ein europäisches kulturgut und diese
und deshalb wünsche ich mir eigentlich
eine selbstbewusste schweiz die davon
ausgeht dass sie nicht nur eine
bevölkerung repräsentiert die durch
wohlstand irgendwie gleichgültig
geworden ist natürlich gibt es solche
menschen und natürlich verstehe ich die
schweizer künstler die gegen eine
gewisse saturiertheit immerfort
ankämpfen da gibt es aber ist denn das
andere das bewusstsein von dem rang
unter würde der bürger existenz ist in
das verloren gegangen
nein es existiert und die schweiz hat
immer wieder als gastgeber etwa des
völkerbunds zwischen den kriegen oder
heute als un standort in genf oder mit
der beheimatung des internationalen
komitees vom roten kreuz mit unendlich
vielen aktiven aktivitäten weltweit
gezeigt dass sie verantwortungsvoll und
diese besondere verantwortung fähigkeit
der schweizer eliten der schweizer
bürgergesellschaft die möchte ich auch
über die grenzen hinaus sehen und
deshalb bin ich sehr gespannt wie es nun
gelingt nach dem neuesten entwicklungen
das verhältnis zur europäischen union
neu zu bestimmen das muss irgendwie ja
auf eine neue basis gestellt werden und
wollen wir dann alles was wir erlangt
haben an gemeinsamkeit über den haufen
werfen da bin ich ganz gespannt was in
den nächsten drei jahren da passieren
wird aber es wird nicht ohne dieses
innere jahr der schweizer bevölkerung
gehen zu ihrer eigenen wunderbaren
demokratiegeschichte und in dem dieses
jahr sich verstärkt und man die eigene
rolle neu und vielleicht auch mit
begeisterung an nimmt ja wir sind auch
ich sag das mal als ausländer
wir sind mit unseren politischen
erfahrungen auch und kulturellen
erfahrungen auch ein geschenk an eine
welt die in zerrissenheit und hass lebt
ja und in dem die bevölkerung dieses
praktisch in die eigene mitte holt dann
werden diese ängste vor überfremdung
auch sich relativieren es wird immer
noch wenige geben das so empfinden aber
jedenfalls von deutschland geht keine
bedrohung aus für für auch von deutschen
zuwanderern nicht und das alles wird
sich wieder in einen gelasseneren
diskurs begeben da bin ich ganz
zuversichtlich
gut dann lassen wir mal das thema europa
und wechselt zu einem anderen thema das
für sie auch ein ganz wichtiges thema
ist nämlich das historische erinnern
wir haben 2014 viele wichtige jahrestage
100 jahre erster weltkrieg 75 jahre
beginnen zweiter weltkrieg ich möchte
aber beginnen mit 25 jahre mauerfall
herr bundespräsident wenn sie dieses
jahr 1989 vor dem geistigen auge
vorbeiziehen lassen welche bilder kommen
ihnen welche bilder haben sich am
meisten eingeprägt ja für alle die dabei
waren vielleicht auch für viele andere
europäer war es ein annus mirabilis ein
unerwartet wunderbares jahr der
selbstermächtigung eine lange
ohnmächtigen bevölkerung denn dass es
mein eigentliches zauberbild nicht der
mauerfall es ist ein schönes bild ikone
weltweit klar das wird auch mich aber
dass der wunderbare und zauberhafte
begehen ist der moment wo jeder in
seiner eigenen stadt zum ersten mal
erkennt ich bin nicht nur produkt meiner
ängste sondern eigentlich bin ich
gemeint und gedacht und angelegt ein
bürger zu sein
ein bürger und ein bürger hat
bürgerrechte und er hat freiheiten und
deshalb sind die stunden in denen in
leipzig am 8
oktober 89 in dresden am 8 oktober in
plauen im vogtland am siebter oktober in
meiner heimatstadt rostock am 14 oktober
in dem sich zum ersten mal die menschen
zu einer solchen bürgerschaft nicht mehr
nur der landesbewohner sondern der
bürger zusammengetan hat sagt hier sind
wir wir sind das volk
das ist für mich der wunderbarste und
leuchtenden moment in einem blutigen
jahrhundert wo gerade die deutschen
unendlich viel schuld auf sich geladen
haben ist es so ein ein wiedererwachen
von einer lange als unmöglich erachteten
fähigkeit einfach zu leben wie ein
freier bürger und das überstrahlt im
grunde diese diesen mauerfall also ich
will mal so sein
vor der einheit und dem symbol der
einheit mauerfall kommt die freiheit und
die freiheit ist das leuchtende und dass
wir dann wieder zu einer nation werden
das ist eigentlich die zugabe
es ist dann mit diesem schönen bild vom
brandenburger tor so sinnfällig
eingeprägt ins kollektive gedächtnis das
ist auch okay aber konnten dann die
bürger im ersten moment mit dieser
plötzlich gewonnenen freiheit umgehen
nein das war sehr mühsam und das ich
denke dass das sehr schwer zu erklären
ist für für bürger die in der schweiz
gross geworden sind
deren vorfahren schon in der schweiz als
freie bürger agiert habe sehr schwer
und nun stehen sich mal eine ostdeutsche
bevölkerung vor die von 1933 bis 1989
also fast drei generationen lang
immerfort zwar unter verschiedenen aber
immer fort unter einer herrschaft von
diktatoren gelebt hat es geht nicht um
die unterschiedliche ideologie die will
ich nicht gleichsetzen
aber die ohnmacht der bevölkerung ist
sehr ähnlich
und die übermacht der mächtigen sie ist
auch sehr ähnlich das heißt du lernst
drei generationen lang günstig und
hilfreich für dein leben in der
gesellschaft ist es den mund zuhalten zu
tun dass die da oben wollen nicht so
laut zu fragen schon gar nicht zu
protestieren sich ein wenig zu fürchten
und immer rechtzeitig anzupassen
das ist die erfolgsspur du lernst nicht
in einem klassenverband
klassensprecherin zu sein du lernst
nicht was es ist eine schülerzeitung zu
machen du lernst nicht in einem
unternehmen was es ist ein freien
betriebsrat zu wählen
eine freie gewerkschaft zu haben alle
diese dinge lernst du nicht du liest
auch nicht unterschiedliche meinungen in
den medien du siehst nicht
unterschiedliche politische ansichten im
fernsehen
und all das geschieht so lange dass
durch schließlich vernommen mal hältst
und das ist das wunderbare dieser
erhebung der bevölkerung das aus der
sehnsucht nach unabhängigkeit und
freiheit heraus dann doch ein abschied
kommt von dieser lebensform des
angepasst seitz des gelebt werden und
dann wenn man dann so weit ist wir sind
frei dann kommt der moment aber frei
wozu nicht wovon sondern wozu und dann
ist dieses kommt diese große
lebensaufgabe erwachsene menschen
freiheit zu definieren als freiheit als
verantwortung als freiheit für uns so
etwas
und da kommt dann wieder acht kann ich
das und deshalb brauchen alle
transformations- gesellschaften mehr
zeit um wirklich diese bürger existenz
in der masse zu leben als es zeit
braucht die institutionen zu verändern
das ging stellten aber das entsprechende
bürger verhalten
das lernt die ganze osteuropäische
bevölkerung immer noch schritt für
schritt und immer noch können wir
mentalitätsunterschiede ausmachen bei
den jugendlichen und jungen leuten nicht
mehr und das ist das schön so das
zwiespältige an der freiheit als wäre er
ich war sehr sehr gut herausgearbeitet
dass der mensch ein maximum an freiheit
eigentlich an
männer sieht dann aber hat kann er nicht
damit umgehen und sie macht ihm angst ja
das ganz schön dass wir in einem
politischen gespräch auf diesen
hintergrund noch einmal kommen denn wir
sind ja nicht nur politische wesen
wir sind ja immer auch individuen mit
der fähigkeit zu träumen und der
fähigkeit und zu fürchten
unsere kräfte auszuprobieren oder ihnen
zu misstrauen
und nein politisch wacher mensch
gleichzeitig die politik aber auch die
psyche des menschen erforscht hat wie
erich fromm der hat darüber sehr plaster
von sehr plastische bilder gemacht
natürlich träumen wir uns als frei wir
haben einen im traum ist freiheit immer
schön das ist nicht schwere arbeit was
freiheit auch sein kann und er sind das
wunderbare bild vor dem paradies
der mensch will frei sein die bibel
nennt es den sündenfall aber kein gebot
soll über mir sein und dann erlangt er
diesen status und dann fragt er
und was passiert im nächsten moment er
ist außerhalb des paradieses und
fürchtet sich davor was der nächste tag
bringen wird sich zurück und sehen sich
dann zurück und deshalb gibt es immer
nach den großen aufbrüchen auch phasen
des kleinods und deshalb brauchen wir in
diesen phasen des aufbruchs wenn der
kleinmut kommt oder sich auch politisch
heimaten verschafft in strömungen nur
gruppen dann brauchen wir diejenigen die
von der schönheit der freiheit gerade
auch wenn sie in der form der
verantwortung also der aufgabe zu uns
kommt überzeugt sind und die anderen
menschen ein bild davon geben dass es
schön ist wenn wir einfach das was in
uns lebt an kraft auch an hoffnungs
potenzial wenn wir das umsetzen wenn wir
nicht auf der flucht sind sondern stand
halten und diese diese
du hast nie in der politischen
entwicklung ein zustand wo du davon
ausgehen kann dass dein jahr zur
freiheit zur freiheit als verantwortung
es ist ganz ganz sicher ist sollen diese
dieser staat ist der muss eben immer
wieder von jeder kommenden generation
neu erlangt und er kämpft auch
erstritten werden wenn man sich erinnert
eben an den mauerfall an die
wiedervereinigung dann sind das schöne
erinnerung wenn man sich jetzt als
deutscher aber überhaupt an den zweiten
weltkrieg erinnert dann ist das eine
schwierige erinnerung und sie schreiben
sich das auf die fahne dass man
aufarbeiten muss dass man erinnern muss
wie erinnert man denn richtig als
erreichtes mahnmale aufzustellen und
jedes jahr im jahrestagen kranz
niederzulegen oder wie geht erinnern und
aufarbeiten also das kann man auch mal
das macht man auch das und rituale und
man kann unsere rituale nicht abschaffen
aber eine lebendige erinnerung erschöpft
sich sicher nicht in ritualen und
rituale altern übrigens man man muss
dann wenn man eine glückliche hand hat
er findet man neue die unterschiedlichen
menschen versammeln
in einer emotionalen bewegung hin zu
einem ort des gedenkens oder des eigenen
erinnerung ist eigentlich es wäre so
schön wir könnten sagen wenn der
menschliche erinnert ist er gerettet
aber das ist nicht so als theologe würde
ich sagen
erinnerung ist teil der gefallenen welt
nicht einer heilen welt und deshalb
können der erinnerung auch nicht als
etwas perse lösendes oder gar erlösen
ist definieren ich glaube dass wir uns
nie von der schuld der vergangenheit
wirklich befreien können ohne
erinnerungen aber es gibt auch eine
erinnerung die den irrtum konserviert
und die destruktives verhalten
im grunde wieder intendiert schauen sie
wenn die deutschen nach dem ersten
weltkrieg massenhaft davon überzeugt
sind erstens dass sie keine schuld am
krieg ich will gar nicht die schuldfrage
am ersten weltkrieg ausführlich
debattieren aber es gibt gründe sich
danach zu fragen welche nationen wie
viel anteil haben und der anteil der
deutschen ist nicht gering
aber als die mehrheit der deutschen das
kriegsende dann erlebte mit dem
versailler vertrag der schwer war für
deutschland der vielleicht auch nicht
völlig gerecht war das würde ich gerne
sagen habe dann kommt eine erinnerung an
den ersten krieg in der weise wir sind
im felde unbesiegt also wir sind edel in
den krieg gezogen und nur durch einen
dolchstoß in den rücken haben wir
übrigens verloren und dann kann
erinnerung die sich im grunde ein
erinnerungs konstrukt schafft wo eigene
schuld und eigene verantwortung
nachrangig betrachtet wird die fehler
der anderen vorlagen nicht und das
eigene leid fokussiert wird das ist dann
dann kommen wir in so ein dauerfrust
gegenüber der politischen wirklichkeit
und dann entsteht daraus was wir dann
gesehen haben in deutschland ein neuer
und potenzierter nationalismus nicht ein
aufwachen mensch wohin hat uns das gros
machtdenken geführt in einen
unheilvollen wettlauf mit anderen
mächten ist es richtig die nation so ins
zentrum zurück natürlich gibt es ein
paar die so denken und sie gehen in
friedensbewegung oder sind dem
völkerbund aktiv aber eine große menge
fragt sich nein wir müssen noch stärker
sein noch mal wird die nationale karte
gezogen und erinnerung hat bei diesem
prozess sich noch einmal zu verabreden
die größte und wichtigste nation zu sein
einen nicht unerheblichen beitrag
wir sprechen aber und sie sprechen von
einer aufgeklärten erinnerung von einer
erinnerung die das eigene ich nicht
schon von einer erinnerung wie der
mensch wer geheilt werden möchte von
einer psychischen krankheit und da eine
therapie aufsucht und deshalb sich nicht
fürchtet vor den abgründen in sich
selber
und das ist die erinnerung die
deutschland hat wieder wieder heil
gemacht hat als die deutschen die phase
nach dem krieg verdrängen weglaufen
beendet hatte und insbesondere nach der
68er bewegung die frage der schuld
wirklich in den fokus gerückt hat wo
waren meine eltern wo war ich und
versucht hat dieser schande und dieser
schmach dieser charme auch dieser trauer
standzuhalten
da beginnt ein befreiungsplatz und das
ist eben das wunderbare das erinnerung
dann eben doch uns dazu verhelfen kann
nicht nur unsere eigene größe an unsere
grenzen unsere fehlbarkeit aufzuzeigen
und dann werden wir kooperative wir
werden empathischer wir sehen den
anderen nicht als etwas bedrohen das
leben uns sondern als ein menschenwesen
oder als eine bevölkerung mit der wir
doch gut zusammen leben können und ich
bin total glücklich wissen sie präsident
eines deutschland zu sein der so einen
text sprechen kann und ich sag das nicht
als irgendein wunschtraum sondern
aufgrund von diesen erfahrungen aus der
verdrängung aufwachen erinnerung zu
lassen
schmerz zulassen versuchen wieder
gutzumachen und dann plötzlich erlebe
ich meine nation die ich als junger
mensch gehasst habe aus trauer alten aus
enttäuschung wegen der mordtaten und ich
erlebe sie plötzlich als ein gemeinwesen
für das ich danke sagen kann es ist so
so etwas lebendig machen das und
eigentlich auch etwas einladendes und
dann haben wir es manchmal an und salz
deutsche zu sagen schaut ist es uns auch
gelungen uns frei zu schwimmen und
erinnerungen tut nicht wirklich weh es
tut weh aber gerade wenn du die
schmerzen aus kommst du in eine form von
neuen lebensmöglichkeiten
die einfach wunderbar ist es gibt
natürlich auch stimmen die sagen sie in
deutschland ist jetzt auch mal gut wir
haben jetzt 100.000 hitler dokus im
fernsehen gesehen und wir haben es in
der schule eks mal durchgekaut und wir
können es eigentlich nicht mehr hören
ich geht man damit wir schauen an wer
spricht wenn ein rechtsradikaler oder
auch nur ein nationalist so spricht dann
werden wir ihm sagen schwaig du hast
kein alternativangebot wenn ein pädagoge
so spricht oder ein psychologe wenn
einer der sich umschaut welche art von
debatten helfen menschen ermächtigen
menschen und welche stumpfen sie ab dann
hören wir noch einmal zu und dann merken
wir dass man auch gute pädagogische
konzepte vielleicht im übereifer in ein
übermaß bringt und dann wird aus einer
pädagogik die uns zum eigentlichen der
inneren einkehr führen sollte und auch
geführt hat wenn du es zu einem prinzip
erhebt und noch die dritte und vierte
generation ansprichst als wäre sie
schuldig dann begeht man einen
pädagogischen und fehler der die psychen
der heranwachsenden überfordert das ist
auch politisch wenig sinnvoll
und darum müssen wir uns von einer
ritualisierung eine einschüchterung
erinnerung hüten
wir wollen keine erinnerung die uns
einschüchtern und uns sagt wir sind so
schlecht und so bedrohlich dass wir am
besten aus dem verkehr gezogen werden
sondern wir wollen eine erinnerung die
uns das scheitern auch als aktuelle
lebensraum vor augen führt niemals sind
wir so sicher dass wir darauf verzichten
können unsere werte uns bewusst zu
machen sie zu sprechen und zu
verteidigen und das ist die form einer
lebendigen erinnerung nicht der kranz
dorthin noch ein denkmal noch größer als
sondern die verbindung unseres
scheiterns und unseres
neu auf uns nicht verlassen kannst diese
erfahrung die gehören zusammen und dann
wird aus der erinnerung etwas was nicht
schematisch ich kann mir schon denken
das noch mal wieder ein hitler titel in
einem bedeutenden bleibt noch mal wieder
einer dass das auch eine form von
erinnerung ist die die unfruchtbar
sie sind wir die direkte
nachkriegsgeneration sie haben sagt ein
bisschen angesprochen war dass in ihrer
familie thema haben sie ihre eltern auch
gefragt oder auch mit vorwürfen
konfrontiert warum habt ihr nicht
gerichtet es gibt also sagen wir mal die
mehrheit der der deutschen denke ich hat
mit ihren eltern versucht über diese
zeit zu sprechen wo warst du weißt du
gemacht
die meisten meiner generation haben
früher aufgehört zu fragen weil zu wenig
kam und wir haben auch vielleicht nur
eine form der frage gewählt ein bisschen
neugier und b wenn wir dann politischer
wurden im jugendlichen alter waren wir
auch oft die ankläger ich jedenfalls war
so einer
dann hab meinen eltern die mitläufer
waren in der nazi-zeit mein vater hatte
gott sei dank nicht schießen müssen im
krieg war lehrer gewesen an der
marineschule conti mir persönlich nichts
anhaben aber das eher mitläufer war das
habe ich ihm vorgeworfen hatten uns
eigentlich anders setzungen und meine
mutter genauso
und wenn man das dann an sprach dann kam
kaum erinnerungen dann wurde ihm noch
erzählt warum man anfangs für hitler
sein konnte ihn wählen konnte wegen der
arbeitslosigkeit und wie schlechtesten
deutschen gehen und ja das hatte man nun
schon hundertmal gehört man hätte mal
gerne ein wort des bedauerns gehört ja
mein gott wo bin ich rein geraten aber
nicht mal das kam bei den meisten und
deshalb sind sehr viele meiner
generation dann in der 68er bewegung so
rigoros geworden dass sie mit der
elterngeneration gleich das ganze system
abgelehnt haben das war im osten nicht
so weil wir hatten diktatur und hat eine
eigene probleme brauchen die eltern auch
als verbündete gegen unsere diktatoren
aber im westen wo die freiheit war
er wollte sich die junge generation mit
dem schweigen nicht abfinden und das war
was sehr interessant ist damals als die
mehrheit schweigt gab es immer schon
eine minderheit die geredet hat es gab
die überlebenden opfer es gab die
emigranten die zurückgekommen war
es gab die wissenschaftler und diejenige
die politisch und kulturell niemals
etwas mit den nazis an gut halten und
die waren schon ziemlich rigide eugen
kogon schreibt sehr früh sein buch der
ss staat und viele andere
veröffentlichung aber das ist ein sub
diskurs die mehrheit der bevölkerung
sagt sie ja auch nicht alles schlimm
beim führer
das ist dann eine eine redensart die wie
immer wieder treffen
fahren sie heute dort hin wo in
südamerika diktatur war dann können sie
denselben satz es war auch nicht alles
schlimm bei pino gentile und nach dem
ende des kommunismus kam der satz auch
auf das heißt es gibt schon so eine
natürliche tendenz der menschen zu
verteidigen und das besondere jetzt an
der deutschen nachkriegsgeschichte war
dass die schuld war so groß dass das mit
dem fett drängen nicht funktionieren
naja und bei meinen eltern war es so die
sind in das späte ich meine hier mit dem
kopf waren sie dann natürlich relativ
früh da das sie gemerkt haben sie waren
auf einem falschen trip als die
mitläufer waren aber mit dem herzen kam
es erst eine generation später ich war
erwachsen
ich habe das ruhig einmal erzählen es
gab im fernsehen die serie der holocaust
aus amerika eine darstellung politischer
verfolgung im stil einer soap-opera also
claude lanzmann und andere war nicht
beglückt über das produkt aber es war
unglaublich massenwirksam die leute
haben nicht in einer pädagogischen weise
noch einmal gehört was der holocaust war
sondern in einer erzählung über eine
ganz normale deutsche familie die
familie weiß und meine eltern die von
mir schon genug angegriffen worden waren
der jugend sitzen als alte leute vor dem
fernseher gucken da westfernsehen konnte
man bei uns empfangen diese geschichte
und ich komme abends zu ihnen und die
tränen laufen ihnen über die wangen
und ich sage was ist und sie sagt da
hitler die judenverfolgung und ich sagte
zu ihnen aber ich habe es doch immer
schon zu euch gesagt ja ich nicht recht
erinnern sie hatte sich abgeblockt
kriegen meine haltung eines
staatsanwaltes du junger bengel
hier steht das nicht zu sie hatten sich
hart gemacht gegen angriffe aber als in
einer mitmenschen worten eine menschen
geschichte erzählt
da ging es ums herz rein und das war für
mich natürlich eine sehr späte aber dann
doch eine genugtuung dass das menschen
die sich länger getrennt hatten von
dieser erinnerung die eines schwereren
geht dann das schmerzhafte dass die dann
doch irgendwann zu erreichen sind ja
leider ist unsere zeit fast um eine
letzte frage herr bundespräsident
was glauben sie denn was spätere
generationen uns vorwerfen werden machen
was werden sie sagen warum wartet
ablehnt kurze antwort es schwer das zu
sehen weil es probleme sein können für
die wir eine rationale erläuterung haben
wir können unseren kindern und enkeln
vielleicht später erklären warum die
flüchtlinge die jetzt zu uns wollen
nicht zu uns kommen können
vielleicht können wir es erklären
vielleicht aber werden sie uns die frage
stellen wie viele waren es genau und
hattet ihr wirklich keinen platz und es
könnte sein dass wir denn keine antwort
haben und sagen das habe ich damals gar
nicht als so ein problem gesehen und
deshalb müssen wir damit rechnen dass
auch unterhalb des wehres schuldig zu
werden an massenmord jede menge
gelegenheiten existieren die uns
gegebenen möglichkeiten von
mitmenschlichkeit und gute miteinander
nicht zu sehen sondern sie zu vergessen
oder gering zu
kommen wir wieder dazu demokratie will
immer wieder in jeder generation nicht
neu erfunden aber neu entdeckt und
bejaht werden
dazu hilft schauen dieses erinnern dass
genau hinschaut
herr bundespräsident ich bedanke mich
sehr herzlich für dieses gespräch
[Musik]
dieses gespräch können sie
selbstverständlich nochmals 10 auf
unserer website nächste woche sprechen
wir hier über gräueltaten und kunst im
gespräch mit milo rau und juliane
rebentisch fragen wir wo liegen die
grenzen des ästhetischen und kammern zum
beispiel ein kunstwerk schaffen über
etwas wie den völkermord in ruanda im
hier und jetzt aber geht es weiter mit
kunst die zum teil in ihrer zeit
ebenfalls umstritten war
teil 2 der bbc dokumentation art auf
amerika folgt malern des 20 jahrhunderts
wie edward hopper jackson pollock und
markt lotto